welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ned blackhawk a professor of history
and american studies at Yale his field
of interest is American Indian history
and he's the author of violence over the
land Indians and empires in the early
American West a study of the American
Great Basin that garnered numerous
professional prizes including the
Frederick Jackson Turner prize from the
Organization of American Historians is
also published numerous state of the
field essays from many of America's
leading professional historical
associations and has helped to build the
newly established Native American
cultural center here at Yale today we'll
talk with professor blackhawk about the
Yale group for the study of Native
America and his broader work to
institutionalize Native American Studies
welcome professor Black Hawk it's very
nice to be here let's start with an
overview of the Yale's group for the
study of Native America tell us about it
and its mission the yo group for the
study of Native America is a
interdisciplinary working group on
campus we refer to it as yyx know the
kind of acronym and it provides a
permanent space and a kind of community
for the city of Native America that
draws upon Yale's largely graduate
student but also faculty and staff
interest in this subject and what's its
mission our goal is to provide a
supportive inclusive and advanced
scholarly community for interested
participants who need or want to share
their work with a professional audience
of some form and to provide even more so
a kind of community around campus on
these issues draw
a draws from various professional
schools we have a lot of law students
various academic graduate programs and
also from an increasing number of
faculty on campus interested in these
subjects and how long has it been on
campus here it was founded in 2003 by a
group of concerned graduate students
that Yale like many other private
institutions at the time didn't have a
very prominent kind of scholarly profile
in the field of not just American Indian
history which is my field of study but
also Native American legal studies
Native American literary studies and the
graphic work art history and other types
of academic fields of inquiry these
students really kind of heroically built
a institutional space secured funding
for annual conferences and set in motion
some of the pressure on the
administration to begin the process of
hiring an academic faculty in the fields
and what are some of the projects that
you're working on with the group we're
doing lots of things so it's really
quite exciting
we run a bi-monthly working group that
meets in the newly established Native
American Cultural Center we showcase
emergent works in the field from some of
our graduate students who are finishing
dissertation chapters or research
projects doing initial kind of
publications we sponsor lots of academic
talks and events on campus this year
alone we've done two very large at least
in organization conferences that have
drawn collectively around a hundred
people to campus from across North
America on various kind of academically
themes subjects we also run a
dissertation of writing fellowship I'm
named after one of the most illustrious
early twentieth-century Native American
graduates named Henry Rho cloud ok this
fellowship brings visiting graduate
student to campus for the year to finish
the dissertation and is drawn from a
international pool of applicants and we
provide the kind of scholarly community
in which this fellow
does their academic work and then
presents it to a audience we also run
them not so much as a working group but
many of us are involved in other Native
American Studies efforts on campus and
at Yale including the running of a
University Press Series with the Yale in
American Indian studies okay are there a
number of these kinds of groups at
universities and colleges across the
country or not so many
well Yale is kind of a very active
academic community so it has lots of
comparable or heavily institutionalize
academic working communities there's
this famous one that you're probably
familiar with in agrarian studies run by
James Scott I have colleagues in the
history department who run sets of these
working groups so when I arrived here
about 6 or 7 years ago I began that well
I worked with people who were involved
in that earlier phases of this group and
helped secure kind of permanent
resources for it
so we're not unique here in a sense
except that we're the only group on
campus or does any American Studies but
we are in fact the only to my knowledge
professional academic working group of
its kind across any of the kind of
leading private institutions labor okay
that's wonderful it is but it's also
kind of sad in a sense that there aren't
that many other advanced communities in
this field right so the cultural center
tell us about that
what is it comprised of the Native
American cultural center is becoming one
of the most enriching places on campus I
think it's not I think it's not a unfair
to kind of use that very strong
characterization to describe this really
vibrant largely undergraduate student
community but very active and close
academic community on campus it's one of
the four cultural centers on campus that
is designed to provide a secure and
supportive community for
underrepresented students of color in
this case Native American students and
indigenous students from across largely
North America we have Alaska Native
students Native Hawaiian students and
nearly a record number of American
Indian undergraduates at the moment and
how many would that be
I think we're graduating fifty need
itself even if I knew the American
students in this year which is nearly
four percent of the entire student body
graduating class that's pretty amazing
actually it is and it reflects the kind
of growing institutional concern and
interest in these areas the center is
only two years old now so it has really
kind of state-of-the-art some in our
space and kitchen and other types of
amenities and one of the really most
exciting things is that there were once
only one or two really active Native
American student groups on campus and
now we have eight or nine Wow both
undergraduate and graduate students and
all of them generally use the center as
the site for their meetings in a lot of
their events and are they broken out by
basically different parts of the country
in terms of the Native American nation
that they're affiliated with less so
there are some at some institutions
there will be like a native Hawaiian
group or a Navajo student community club
or some kind of Association these groups
are kind of organized around student
interests and things like health or our
law students have a group or our Native
American graduate students have an
active group the working group is
another group that's affiliated in part
with the center but the undergraduates
also have a drumming group
so it's more it's more than just
centered around the artistic part of
Native Americans correct it's really a
academic as well as scholarly so where
would you like to see that the cultural
center go in the next five years it'd be
really nice to see a few more additional
Native American faculty on campus are
you the only one at this moment I'm in
college and it'd be really nice to see
some more kind of collaborative
partnerships between campus and other
Native American either institutional
programs or even communities themselves
on Indian country you've done a few
really interesting collaborations with
the Mohegan nation here in Connecticut
we've had events at the Pequot museum
also and I've recently hired a few
Native American community leaders from
across campus to work with us in various
ways okay let's talk about your academic
work you recently completed an anthology
with Isaiah Willner called indigenous
visions rediscovering the world of Franz
boas let's tell us about Franz Boas who
who he is and then let's talk a little
bit about the anthology and what it grew
out of the legacy of anthropology in the
field of American Indian studies is
really hard to overestimate or
overemphasize anthropology is a kind of
scholarly field emerged in the late 19th
early 20th century and really had as its
primary subjects of inquiry indigenous
communities largely in North America and
the kind of leading proponent or the
kind of institutional founder of that
discipline was a German ethnologist by
the name of Franz boas who migrated out
of Germany in the late 18-hundreds and
traveled around North America
and eventually helped organize like
incredibly extensive cultural
exhibitions like at the World's Fair in
Chicago in 1893 and eventually worked
for decades in New York City
institutionalizing the discipline of
anthropology at Columbia University and
also building like the New York Sun
Natural History Museum and and then
training dozens and dozens of a future
anthropologists many of whom would study
native languages and begin recording
what they thought were disappearing
cultural practices and really helped
establish a kind of academic vernacular
and institutional understanding of the
peoples of the world in which Native
Americans were usually you had the
sentiment or the primary
ethnographically identifiable other to
Western societies emergent in the sense
of its own subjectivity so we have this
very robust now community of graduate
students here one of them is writing a
academic dissertation on not just boas
but the particularly the Native American
communities that shaped and informed him
and he very relatively early on in his
graduate training decided he'd like to
do a big conference and so using our
yyyx networking group and working with
macmillan where we held the the event we
brought together a dozens of scholars
for a few days and really interrogated
the relative place not only of Boaz as a
kind of ethnographic influencer of
subsequent scholarly debates but
particularly those who shaped him okay
so the world around him and we came to
release kind of firm understanding that
we shouldn't think of these intellectual
leaders and certain scholarly fields as
being singular figures but having been
deeply imprinted by particularly their
native informants so we spent quite a
bit of time working with these visiting
scholars and
soliciting extended papers from them and
have compiled them into a volume that
really rethinks the legacy of not just
in a sense boas but really of American
Anthropological thought and so what are
some of the conclusions that came out of
it well a kind of primacy of one of the
kind of primary conclusions is that the
world in which anthropologists were
forming their ideas about native peoples
was not something that they alone were
constructing and that there are many
attempts both here and also globally
where various ethnographic informants
were trying to in a sense articulate a
certain social or kind of cultural or
even political vision through the
discourse of ethnography in a sense have
the ethnographer understand their
concerns and potentially bring them to
other colonial or Imperial officials or
help redress the levels of say cultural
censorship that they were experiencing
so boaz it was most famous for working
among the Northwest coasts indigenous
communities particularly in British
Columbia and those communities at the
time he was there and at the time he
brought them or helped bring them to
Chicago were undergoing very heavy
persecution of their cultural and
religious practices and so they saw in
him an ally who could help articulate a
vision of their cultural organization to
outsiders at a time when government
officials and missionaries and various
kind of institutions of the state were
heavily prosecuting them so we're
looking at the kind of dynamic agency
that indigenous peoples have been able
to deploy at various times through these
sets of ethnographic encounters and how
do you think that would apply to Native
America today well I think it's relevant
to think of indigenous peoples as having
been very active participants in the
making of both the intellectual
structures that have historically under
recognized them
as well as the larger societies around
them so the idea that museums or
scholarly text books or children's
literature convey that these peoples are
without history or primitive or somehow
inherently different is in fact the kind
of message that native peoples have been
contesting for generations
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work it's
been a pleasure for more information
about Professor Black Hawk and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you